I press at reviewing its footage I kind
of realized I got way too into this game
it's ridiculous when I hated myself
saying in the end I'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing but yeah I'm gonna upload it
anyway
so I hope you enjoy I [ __ ] love this
game anyway how's it going bro my name
is Bearpaw welcome to parappa the rapper
part 2 it's been a while since I did the
other one
it didn't really was I think a lot of
people judged it because it looks kind
of like a kids game well even if it is a
kids game it's the [ __ ] hardest game
I ever played I'm on song number 2 I
swear to God I will not be able to
finish it
alright here we go guys
we did for [ __ ] in the car I want
you to show with you and get far
step on the gas [ __ ] step on breaks
fine step on the gas
I have a control it out this [ __ ] music
bam bam bam come boy come on right down
step on the gas
Debra got on the brakes step on the
brakes on the brake
step on the brakes on the guy what you
ready to go ain't gonna stop me here we
go turn the singing to the right check
and turn Seguin still right now now turn
to the right
yeah we're a good rest in turn ii
started right check turn take us to the
rock down now turn to the left
five-o
stop the car we got an emergency can I
try this meta time to dig it why we
stopped the car do I know when we
stopped at all yes
but do you know why we stopped the car
do I know where we stop the car yeah
what what
suppose then oh you forgot to close the
door
alright so far so good maybe I can
actually live it mmm thank you okay
just kidding no scram I mean not kidding
check turn the signal to the right
Jack turn sega's do the right oh [ __ ]
step on the gas now turn to the right
the signature left take turn singers to
the left
now turn to the left Decco the gaff now
turn to the left step on the brake are
we stop the car why you know where we
stopped the car again
bah he'll got a do it [ __ ] I was so
close holy [ __ ] what what attempt number
305 million
we stopped the car again do do I know
why we stopped the car again [ __ ] [ __ ] I
could never do that
Shabana what eggs OS the car again
you've got a dick I just rub the thick
game what I'm really sorry
y'all gotta do it again
I forgot to close the door you forgot to
close the door hmm all right we're good
we can do this right
Hector the second to the right step on
the gas now turn to the right have fun
together
turn to the right check listen move to
the left to check to turn the Cygnus
noted hat
step on the gas now turn to step on the
gas
turn to the step on the brakes step on
the brake do you know come on Betty do
you know when we stopped large that's
because you just got is good what is
this go away
I got way too excited for that yes oh
right I just [ __ ] safe holy [ __ ] that
was difficult I spit all over my
yes
hey not okay breasts I got my dad's
gonna bite me Parappa hey Parappa that's
a you're going with my car
hey forever karappa karappa can manager
aha sorry Jesus Christ he's gonna get
laid that's what it's gonna do
holy [ __ ]
hi
oh my god has got a duck in the front
Barabbas gotta get laid Barabbas gonna
get wadies to dreaming all this
what
this is really a lot of fun yeah I'm
just traveling go someplace I guess yeah
what the hell is going on I told you I
was gonna get laid all right he goes for
the move
[ __ ] Lauper Abbas dad all right
cool what's going on sit up
oh no I can't believe
look days gonna brighten no one in the
[ __ ] car reacted to 59 more monthlies
don't miss to pay what am I going to
tell your mother I hope you're ready to
pay for everything I'm in trouble now
how am I gonna pay for this car how can
I do that
yeah I know I got to believe yay
so you all to sell goods at this
remarketing oh I got like this sign this
on you until oh hey math and singing
selling goods here hey what a pip it's
tough for Islam oh yeah hey want to sell
goods here all right
don't stop nip to me [ __ ] love this
game man all right and follow your lead
[ __ ] yeah in this game I'm gonna be
awesome digging this [ __ ] pig in the
[ __ ]
why does he has a skunk but it's up with
this I'm working in the middle I don't
earn a I've been working here since my
baby week just because the rhythm is
slow the domain does your count flow
this arena only [ __ ] in the rain comes
about the funky flow down the [ __ ]
[ __ ] arena in the snow and then right
now in this house about the funky flow
got forgot the [ __ ] chose to upon the
glory shines on friends all your ever
needed to be 90 legs do do stupid [ __ ]
look all you haven't needed to be nice
and pragmatic boss try to bridge the key
is uh-huh I love everybody from way up
up oh say what Prez I consult with your
blood I can tell up kappa but like their
icon sellable booty up like me i can say
like up a bus like this
one ruler officer Bunty is gone a year
we bring calc away we bring you life
complete rub the pump away come back oh
[ __ ] I got a Content in the school in
the radar in the cells about the funk
you got you got your [ __ ] slow are
you serious
jelly a mother [ __ ] me mad I love this
game
that's awesome I you brush know I love
music games this is this [ __ ] awesome
that that second song is difficult as
[ __ ] but I think I'll overcome this one
I really hope you want me to play more
than this I'm gonna decide if I don't
get a chance to play more on it anyway I
can fight it if you enjoyed subscribe
come with road today and I'll see you
next episode Oh ba ba Mei that's right
MA
the game plays like guitar kick punch to
the hole in device if you wanna teach me
I do your eyes the things a teacher she
don't want to be king king but punch
[ __ ] chop